hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with matthew syed
and christina patterson good evening to
you both so let's have a look at what's
on some of those front pages now
the guardian reports labour leader sakir
stama's leadership is in crisis over its
reshuffle
and moving of angela rayner to a new
role the metro looks at restrictions
easing next week including hugging your
loved ones again
the mirror also leads with that story
and it's also featured on the front of
the mail which says curbs will be eased
on funerals
pubs and holidays our new freedoms will
be here to stay is what the prime
minister is expected to say
tomorrow that's on the daily express
copper crisis brewing the daily star
leads with how climate change
may wipe out the nation's favorite drink
and we're joined tonight by columnist
for the sunday times and the times
matthew syed and the journalist and
author christina patterson
hello to you both good to see you um
we're going to kick off
with labour and it's reshuffle on the
front
of the guardian at matthew now
the details of the reshuffle came just
before 10 o'clock
too late for the first editions of the
papers
uh leadership in crisis over reshuffle
moves to demote
angela rayna the headline in the
guardian although she's ended up with
a pretty long slew of titles now matthew
yes so i obviously the uh election
results particularly in england were
very disappointing
uh for labour so understandably
kierstarma
is under a little bit of pressure but i
i think it is worth remembering he
hasn't been leader for that long
uh he's been leader during a
particularly difficult time for a
opposition politician during a pandemic
a national crisis
so i think he deserves more time i think
this story
personally is being blown out of all
proportion a popular deputy leader
uh kyostama clearly took a decision to
make a decisive move
to take her out of the campaigning role
that she had i i think that the vast
majority of the country
uh won't know who angela rainer is and
will be
even less concerned about other details
of the
reshuffle the big question for labour is
whether starmah as a leader can connect
effectively
as we come out of the pandemic and lay
on an alternative to
a conservative party that has moved into
the center-left position on economic
policy
uh a huge demographic shift that we're
undergoing that i think is
bamboozling a lot of political
commentators uh
and i think it's an open question
whether sama will be able to do that but
the leadership in crisis over a
reshuffle i think is a ridiculous
uh notion inside this double page spread
inside the mail
christina could it be curtains fakier
uh suggesting that he's being hit with
the threat of a leadership challenge
just over a year into the job after
uh the elections do you think that's
likely
who knows i mean unfortunately says it
all
well unfortunately the labour party is
incredibly good
at inviting and i do think one of the
things that kiyostama has done
relatively effectively over the last
years or 13 months since he took over as
leader of the labour party has been to
reduce the infighting he ran on a ticket
of being
a unifying figure frankly that was a
rather tall order given the
horrific uh strife that was going on in
the labour party and
he is trying to do a pretty impossible
thing which is
to take a party a party machine that is
dominated by
extremely left-wing uh people
many of them jeremy corbyn supporters
who as we know were
and we know that uh corbyn's labor was
hugely dismissed at the last election
and trying to make the party electable
with people in the so-called red wall
who could not have less interest or
sympathy
with the corbyn project so culturally
that is
i mean pretty impossible i agree with a
lot of what
matthew said i think all of this is a
bit
early and a bit dramatic i think most
people won't know who angela
rainer is i think it was unfortunate
that that was announced straight away
although
there is some suggestion that it might
have been a leak from her to enhance her
leadership um possibilities for the
future
who knows but the last thing that labour
needs at the moment is more infighting
and it looks
so that's exactly what it's going to get
i mean angela rainer a pretty high
profile woman within
the shadow cabinet um and as you say
unfortunately the way it was briefed
last night
it seemed that she'd been sacked now
whether there's been some
uh rowing back or not she's got these
titles let's have a look at what she is
now she's deputy leader still
that's an elected role shadow first
secretary of state shadow chancellor of
the duchy of lancaster
and shadow secretary of state for the
future of
work um i don't even know what all of
those mean
frankly i don't know about you but um
she seems to have got a whole lot more
jobs annelise
dodds she's been moved from the shadow
chancellor role
to party chair and in charge of policy
review at rachel reeves moving into the
shadow chancellor
role and where's streeting in charge of
child poverty
is that new look shadow cabinet going to
be
enough to make a difference for
kierstarma moving into his second year
matthew go ahead well i i was just going
to say i
i think that most people will be
completely dramatically
uninterested in in the the shape of the
shadow cabinet this far away from the
general election
um i i think what christina said is
absolutely right that if i had to give
one piece of advice to kierstama and
anybody
else who is involved in the labour
leadership it is to completely
ignore what the left-wing corbynite
set on twitter is saying day by day
they are well followed on the social
media
by a tiny trivial sliver
of the british uh population
they don't reflect at all the way that
most of people in this country think
and almost the contrary to what the
people that labor
need to win back and i think people tend
to look on twitter and think it is
somehow representative of the real world
it is
completely unrepresentative and that
niche
of the hardcore left i follow them as a
political
somebody who commentates on politics i
have to um but it's a largely deluded
group of people and i would strongly
urge the labour leadership just not to
look
um and if they do look to immediately
disregard or whatever they're saying to
do the opposite
it's not just on twitter though is it
christina because he does have serious
questions to answer about labour's
performance
in the local elections and those
questions are coming from within his own
shadow cabinet within his own party uh
on the labour
benches and he's being compared to a
neil kinnick
michael howard type figure someone who's
never going to make it
uh to the big job just there to as a
holding
leader well i think to be honest
after the last election it was the
chances of labor being elected at the
next election were so tiny because i
don't think
any party has ever come back from that
kind of majority in
one term so i think the likelihood was
that whoever became leader at that point
was likely to be
a holding leader i think i think that
kirsten has disappointed many people
including i have to say me i have no
doubt that he is
well he's clearly very bright he's
honorable he does have principles
he was infinitely better than jeremy
corbyn
and probably the best leader available
though personally i think someone like
yvette cooper would be
much better whether she would have the
popular appeal i don't know but what is
now clear is that boris johnson
is a juggernaut and it doesn't matter
how much he spends on curtains how many
affairs he has how many children he has
what he spends his money on what he gets
tory funders to fund
people just don't care they want or many
people apparently don't care i care
actually weirdly as it happens but many
people don't seem to care
what they do care about what we all care
about is a getting
vaccinated and out of this pandemic and
it's been extremely good luck for the
tory party
and indeed for labor in wales and the
snp in scotland
that uh incumbents tend to be rewarded
at a time of success like this and
everybody just wants to get out of this
thing
and the other thing people care about is
their jobs and futures
now the conservatives have made huge
promises on that front to
the red wall seats i doubt that they can
keep those promises they can pour money
in they will pull money in because they
are now the big spenders but how much
difference that will ultimately make
these are problems that go back
decades okay um let's take a pause
christina and matthew we're going to be
back in just a few minutes
and we're going to be looking at the
restrictions that are easing next week
including being able to hug your loved
ones
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm adam parsons i'm skye's europe
correspondent based here in brussels
more flares going off a volley of rocks
bubbles have been pulled up out and have
been used as missiles
help at these plates
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place
for news we have now
left italy and entered france nobody's
asked to check our identity
made by people who dare to challenge
nice to see you again mr barney
why committing you fishing does have the
potential
to stymie an enormous economic feeling
what strikes you when you come to this
glacier is not just the way in which the
environment is changing
but the speed at which those changes are
happening
it's uh devastating actually
[Music]
i grew up seeing the impacts of climate
change firsthand
having to be afraid of drowning in my
own bedroom
and sometimes waking up in the middle of
the night with flood water in my room
we needed an organization that
specifically talked about the climate
and so me and my friends we
decided to put up youth advocates for
climate action philippines i had to join
the fight
hi my name is zambi zambi mache
and i'm the founder of django makers
limited our first
product lineup pavers which are used for
sidewalks food parts and driveways
and i was reproduced using recycled
lewis plastic
and in 2020 we launched the product
officially in the market
let's turn trash into cash
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now is matthew syed and
christina patterson
uh the metro front page darling hugs of
may its headline we're going to be
hearing from boris johnson
matthew tomorrow outlining the next
stage of easing
restrictions among them contact between
family and friends yeah absolutely
wonderful
wonderful news and a tribute to how well
this country has delivered
the vaccine um and i just think that we
you know we're social animals and i have
missed the
uh physical contact with members of my
immediate family my extended family
people that i care about deeply and have
missed terribly
uh over time zoom uh i'm hoping we're
gonna come back into the sky
studio at some stage uh but i'm gonna
say zoom isn't the same come back
soon yes wouldn't it be lovely i mean i
know
you know you have to leave the you have
to leave the comfort of one's own living
room the slightly odd
corner of the living room that i've been
doing my sky newspaper
i love your books by the way christy
i'll miss looking over your shoulder at
your diary
but i i think it's just going to be
marvellous the i hope the economy like
in the roaring 20s after the spanish flu
i i just hope it takes off
um i think there's a lot to be
optimistic about but i know everyone
says it and i'll say it too we we have
to have some caution too
um our final story christina if my mum
is watching now we'll give her
nightmares and send her into meltdown
a copper crisis is brewing
i know my god as if a pandemic wasn't
bad enough now uh
now global global warming might end t
i make i drink i had a tea or coffee all
day long mostly tea
and i generally put the kettle on before
i have finished my current cup
so i the thought of this just is just
horrendous absolutely horrendous
but we let us hope that it's just
scare-mongering to use them
to use a favorite uh tory phrase so um
with any luck it will be fine but i
can't i can't imagine life without tea
i really can't i just love it so much uh
re glide team in the gallery spotted
you're even having a cup of tea during
the paper review christina
i am we'll leave it to you to your tea
christina
matthew cheers thank you very much we'll
see you in the next hour